hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapters two and six of tragic sense
of life miguel de una muno is going to
set out for us
an existentialist problematic that he
thinks
is largely inescapable and unavoidable
for us however much we might like to
deny it
now he does think that there is an
important proviso
that has to be made here when we are
directly engaged in just trying to stay
alive
trying to maintain our existence to
perpetuate
ourselves we we often don't think of
these things because we're concerned
with other objects you know so if we're
in
illness uh perhaps and just struggling
to
maintain ourselves then this won't be
that much of an issue although
these thoughts do arise for people on
their sick beds
if we are trying to you know avoid
being killed famine these sorts of other
issues
if we're stuck working endlessly just to
make enough bread to stay alive for the
next day
these may not arise but for everybody
else he thinks
either these these issues have arisen
for you or
you're hiding from them and they have on
some level arisen for you and you've
made a decision you just haven't
announced that to yourself
and to others so he begins by saying
that
human beings this is something that's
that's essential to us our are
questioning creatures we want to know
as he says the whys of things the cause
and we also want to know the where for
the
end and we want to know this about our
own
existence our own lives so we want to
know
why what brought us into being what is
the purpose of our lives
but we also want to know where are we
going to
end up and it tells us um here we go
whence do i come whence comes the world
in which at
which and by which i live whither do i
go and withered goes everything that
environs me what does it
all mean such are the questions that a
human being asks once they free
themselves from the brutalizing
necessity of laboring for
material sustenance and he says if we
look closely
we will see that beneath these questions
lies the wish not just no
not to know so much the why as
the wherefore not the cause
but the end the meaning of the why
lies in part in the wherefore you can
say well you know
we were created by the gods to serve
them so they wouldn't have to serve each
other as in the babylonian
anuma alish and if being told that
doesn't really supply much of an answer
unless we actually know
okay so what's happening to us then what
what is the status
of these things that we are when we die
do we just simply
vanish back into the primordial crap
that we came from
or the you know we're resolved into the
elements and you know there's little
bits of stardust inside of us and
we'll all become stars eventually or do
we have a personal immortality of some
sort do we live on
through others and legacy within this
life all of these sorts of questions
are very important for for people and so
we want to know where we are going and
we also want to know where is this whole
world
and humanity going because i could have
you know
uh immortality in a way but if the whole
world is gone and it's just me is that a
very good immortality or
you know maybe we're gonna have
immortality but it's like some of these
religious conceptions
where there's you know not just hell but
all these multiple levels of hell
and we'll be in there either permanently
or until somebody prays us out
or until we've you know expiated our
karmic debt or
something like that right there's a lot
of people are like oh i think there's a
better place
that's such a vague you know uh airy
fairy kind of stuff that
nobody can really take much consolation
in that for for very long right we want
to know where
we're actually going it's a better place
what kind of better place what kind of
better existence
and so you know if you look at the
culture and history of humanity it's
it's replete with description after
description after description of
things that might be the case this even
plays a role in philosophy think about
plato's apology
socrates consoles his uh
you know the people surrounding him as
supporters and interlocutors by saying
well they're going to condemn me to
death but
not that big of a deal you know either
death is a big sleep
and he gives a totally implausible
argument for that
or i'm going to go down to hades and
then i'm going to wrang all the dead
down there and find out who's really a
hero and who's not
and they won't be able to get away from
me by shutting me up and killing me
the way they did up here well you know
this plays
a central role in philosophy we are
interested in these questions
so there's a problematic that's being
laid out
according to una muno and he says that
there's three fundamental
solutions to it so this is early on
in the book this is in chapter 2 the
starting point
towards the end of the chapter he says
why do i wish
to know whence i come and whether i go
whence comes and wither goes
everything that environs me and what is
the meaning of it all
it says for i wish i do not wish to die
utterly and i wish to know whether i am
to die
or not definitely if i do not die what
is my destiny if i die
then nothing has any meaning for me and
so he says there's three
solutions i know that i shall die
utterly and then irr irremediable
despair
so we should pause on that for for a
moment irremediable means
nothing can actually fix this you know
you can try to remove your despair for a
while by watching
cool stuff on on you know netflix or
hulu or by
shooting up you know or or smoking
something that'll make you feel better
for a while or drinking a lot
or losing yourself in you know not just
having lots of sex but but maybe
passionate affairs that have all the
spice of life
but lurking in the background is going
to be this you're going to die
and that's all there there is and this
is all you
get and there's a kind of you know as a
person ages a kind of patheticness to
trying to
escape this and so irremediable
unavoidable despair and when we talk
about despair
this is a word that a lot of people
don't want to hear
despair is the opposite of hope it's
saying there
is no hope there there's nothing
to to shoot for and
this is something that some
existentialists would say we should
actually embrace
is not saying we should embrace this but
he's saying if you know
like you know if you think that you're
absolutely convinced that you're going
to die then this is
it despair is the natural conclusion of
that
what if you take the opposite i know i
shall not die
utterly meaning that i i'm absolutely
certain
i will not die and then he says
something quite interesting here
resignation resignation about this
this existence that we're in in a
certain sense
having absolute certainty of your
immortality
of the fact that not just a little bit
of you but you
will somehow go on take something out of
life
take something out of the living that
you're engaged in by the way
this is not something of course he talks
about but we have
all sorts of interesting science fiction
and fantasy and you know novels
and uh television shows also horror
explores this as well
what would it be like to live forever
would it be
awesome because oh wow you don't have to
worry about dying or would it suck
because everybody that you know dies and
you know everything passes on and after
a while it's all
as equally unimportant and boring as
anything else the way that some people
picture heaven
sounds like a terrible place to go i
mean the
caricature of like everything's clouds
and angels you know with halos and harps
and white robes
that sounds like the most boring
possible existence some people would say
man i'll take hell instead of that
although hell is going to be you know
pretty pretty bad as well
um if you you know if you have a better
conception of the afterlife
as as many religious people do one
that's much more robust well then
it could be quite interesting but the
the keynote for this life would be
resignation
then he says something really
interesting and this is this is the
position that um
is going to take i cannot know
either one or the other and then
we have conflict what does that conflict
look like he says
resignation in despair or despair and
resignation
a desperate resignation or a resigned
despair
and hence conflict and he'll talk about
this throughout the book
a conflict between reason and feeling a
conflict between reason
and life this is what the tragic sense
of
life consists in and looks like them the
very title
of the the work the whole subject matter
of the work
is sort of encapsulated in this moment
and we could go back and forth we could
say well
i'm doubtful now i don't really know but
eventually i realize no this is it i'm
going to die there's nothing left after
this
or there is going to be immortality or
we could start out with one of these
because you know we were brought up with
a certain catechism
and it could be you know a religious
catechism it could be an
atheist secularist catechism uh we learn
from our parents that you know this is
the way things are and then
we find out that our parents actually
don't know that much compared to anybody
else
uh and that there's been sort of an open
discussion about this
going on pretty much in every culture
that developed
past a certain point for ages and ages
and ages and then we might
fall into the conflict category
right now in um
in chapter six in the depths of the
abyss
una muno is going to expand this in two
important ways and tell us some
interesting things
here he says something that might not be
followed by everybody and there could be
some objections raised he says
the absolute and complete certainty on
the one hand that death
is a complete definite irrevocable
annihilation of personal consciousness
a certainty of the same order is the
certainty that three angles of a
triangle are equal to two right angles
so that would be the the negation right
or um the
the on the other hand the absolute and
complete certainty our personal
consciousness is prolonged
beyond death in these present or in
other conditions and above all including
in itself that strange and adventitious
addition of eternal rewards and
punishments
that'd be the second one he says both of
these certainties alike would make
life impossible for us now isn't that a
strange thing to say
because don't we see a lot of people who
have these
absolute certainties and express them
well we do see people express them
we don't actually peer inside their
heads or their souls
or their hearts and see that that
corresponds to what they indeed do
think and feel there's a lot of people
who will talk
about you know oh we're again we're
going to a better place
you know and you press them on that and
you say how do you know that
what is your basis for absolute
certainty usually it amounts to like
well i just have a feeling
well okay then you might have some
doubts about it that's not absolute
knowledge
or they say well that helps me uh get
through the day oh
really you have a purely pragmatic
attitude about that that's very
interesting that's not the same thing as
knowledge now is it
and once you actually start uncovering
the fact that they don't have knowledge
they often get quite
nervous on the spot why because
they're actually in this third category
they don't really know
and they are caught within conflict and
doubt una muno thinks that within each
of us
in the heart of hearts you might say we
we're not really sure we we can't say
i know i will die utterly because that's
as dogmatic a position
as any religious position he's actually
got something really interesting to say
here about you could call them
anti-religious
crusaders he says
note the greater part of our atheists
and you will see they are atheists from
a kind of rage
rage at not being able to believe there
is a god they are the personal enemies
of god
they have invested nothingness with
substance and personality and their no
god
is an anti-god right uh and you know
whether this is a fair characterization
you certainly can
uh think of many people who are atheists
of this stripe
you know think about the old joke about
you know an atheist a crossfitter and a
vegan walk into a bar how do you know
because they announce it to everybody
when they're coming in
that's that kind of atheist the person
who is has committed
as a religious believer to a position of
knowledge that they don't
really have and is based less on
rationality the rationality is kind of
window dressing
and it's much more based on will and
feeling and you can say this about so
many religious believers as well
so unemuno thinks that we
all have doubts on some level and the
question is do we want to be honest
about those doubts
or not do we want to explore them or do
we want to try to close ourselves
off in one or the other of these
a little bit later he tells us
this is in chapter six again that all of
these
things involve despair
our affirmation is despair our negation
is despair
and from despair we abstain from
affirming and denying
well that's interesting our affirmation
our negation and our abstaining from
from affirming or denying is the
abstaining from affirming or denying is
that actually
this i cannot know one or the other what
what
um other places will call passionate
doubt
i don't think so i think this is
actually you could say
a sort of truncated way of dealing with
this of not
really addressing the conflict you
abstain in a sort of cartesian
i don't know whether things are true or
false that's a position of neutrality
neutrality is not the same thing as
inner conflict between
these these warring or competing or
contradictory ideas
and the attempt to work them out it's
rather another
position of saying i'm going to just put
this off to the side and not think about
it
perfectly compatible by the way with you
know
a hedonistic or consumeristic or
whatever escapist lifestyle
you're going to pursue or losing
yourself in radical politics on the left
or right
or doing all sorts of other things
becoming you know somebody who's
obsessed with a certain kind of
fandom it would be a way of avoiding
this for unemuno if we're going to be
authentic
thinkers and livers and feelers and
willers
real people as he likes to call it
people of
you know flesh and bone we're not going
to be able to
avoid this and we're not going to be
able to lose ourselves just in
abstaining from taking a position
the position that we're going to take is
going to be a messy muddy
complicated one that we're going to have
to continually
work through and we can't avoid
these sorts of matters entirely
except by as he pointed out earlier um
being stuck within an endless cycle of
having to just sustain ourselves once we
get past that once we've
got a little bit of leisure freedom
these issues are going to
arise for us as part of our existential
condition
you